award-winning actor brian cranston is
known for his range both
on stage and on screen he won six emmy
awards for the hit series breaking bad
where he played the iconic role of
walter white
last year he earned his second tony
award for his role in the broadway smash
network now cranston is back on screen
for a new limited drama series called
your honor it airs on showtime a
division of i come cbs
he plays respected new orleans judge
michael desiato who defies the law
to protect his son after a hit and run
i drove away
adam you drove away before
okay
i got you buddy i got you
this is a gripping show and brian
cranston is incredible again
you like intense shows brian cranston
this is really intense
it is i i guess i'm just attracted to
very damaged characters uh and and he is
one for sure
yeah this this show basically asks this
is every parent's nightmare you are a
judge
your son hits someone uh in a car
accident it turns out to be the son of
the biggest
mafia kingpin in the city and you
basically
your lives are now at stake aren't they
well i
i don't know that it's every parent's
nightmare if you're a judge
but uh yeah anything that
that threatens the life of your child an
animal instinct just kicks
off and you would do anything in your
capability to protect him and that's the
that's the premise
of your honor and it's gripping uh
it's exciting and it'll take you on a
ride for sure and the
the ending of the series is going to be
very very shocking it's very hard to go
to bed after you watch one of these
episodes because you're so concerned for
everybody
i don't know brian i started listen i
was just going to watch one episode
because i knew you were coming they had
sent us four
i watched one two three back to back
because i couldn't i wanted to know what
was going to happen and then last night
i watched
episode number four you are so good in
it brian so so so good
and it just shows how thank you gail oh
i mean it just shows though brian how
one
decision leads to another decision leads
to another decision
i was actually in pain watching it
because it affects so many people
in the movie so i'm wondering you play
this judge and as
in preparation for it you went to court
to study other judges what were you
looking for and what did you learn
and how difficult was it for you to walk
in with your brian cranston face
yeah well that's the funny thing about
actors doing research is that you don't
actually know exactly what
you're looking for but you're just like
a dry sponge you just want to take
everything in
and trust that it'll sort through itself
and like a funnel and out comes a sense
of
of what you're going to do with any
particular character it's a
big trust exercise so i did i watched uh
a var variety of different trials in new
orleans
and uh i was able to to come away with
a sense of how i'd want to play this
particular judge
yeah it's funny one of the writers here
when we were introducing you earlier
said uh breaking the bench isn't that
good i like that
breaking the bench you get the play on
breaking bad i thought that was really
good
i think you like playing go ahead go
ahead
well i don't know if that that kind of
writing is going to win an emmy but
i thought it was very clever brian
cranston do you like playing characters
under pressure
do you like that or is it just all good
acting
no i i do i'm for i first respond to the
story if it resonates with me if it
feels
if it's touching if it if it's curious
intellectually if it's socially
important
anything like that that gets me
interested in the story and i put it
aside and i go on to other things
and it's a trigger for me if i pull that
back and i go boy that story is staying
with me
it's usually a good sign that i should
get connected with it even further
brian production on your honor actually
got got shut down
uh as so as virtually all production did
when covet hit
and i know you and both you and your
wife both got coveted
and and had some lingering symptoms
didn't you
well yeah uh we were very lucky as it
turns out we got it early in march
and uh had a few days of achiness
and about a week of extreme lethargy
couldn't sleep enough uh and then the
the residual effect was that we lost our
sense of taste and smell
of course i joke that my wife lost her
sense of taste when she married me
that was 31 years ago but
uh to this day i still have about
i've lost about 25 percent of my
sense of taste and smell wow weird but
you know brian listen i've been smitten
with you for a long time since malcolm
in the middle i've told you that many
many times we used to watch that i loved
you and that and then i read that you
guys
recently had a malcolm in the middle
reunion earlier on zoom i'm so sorry i
miss i'd love to see that do you ever
consider an actual scripted reunion with
the cast what was it like to get back
with them
and look at you brian i don't know if
you can see the tape but look at you
with malcolm in the middle
yeah no i have this
i have a lovely background here that i
could i could actually do the weather
for you
you're equipped for it and based on your
training in what was it network yeah
what was it like to be back with them
would you consider doing something uh
i would absolutely do something uh we
were
it was it had been 20 years this year
that we premiered
yeah and so it's bittersweet you see
these faces of people you haven't seen
in 14 15 years
and and you remember you immediately go
back it's like going to your high school
or college reunion
yeah and you see the face and it
immediately takes you back to that
moment
and uh it's sweet and and and
a little melancholy as well i get it
though well congratulations this thing
is so good brian i can't wait to see how
it ends
brian cranston thank you your honor
premieres this sunday on showtime
hold on it's a heck of a ride